if there was an image for El Salvador
across the last year this would be it
about 65 000 people nearly two percent
of the adult population thrown in prison
the country now has the highest
incarceration rate in the world
of March March the anniversary of the
state of emergency which started it all
police arresting people on Mass
trying to break the grip of the
country's two all-powerful gangs the
MS-13 and burial 18. they've been
terrorizing communities across the
country for years the strategy has been
unsophisticated the flooding of
gang-controlled neighborhoods with
police and army and the arrests
seemed to agree that it's worked
liberating communities like La campanera
formerly a notorious gang stronghold
for heading to a house in the
neighborhood that she bought 15 years
ago but could never live in
I have always prayed to God lord I want
a house where I can live in peace where
no one will bother me and the Lord has
fulfilled it with homicides down and
gang members seemingly fleeing for the
hills around 90 of the population
approve of President naiibu Kelly the
architect of the strategy and he's
doubled down on it building a new
Maximum Security Prison to fill with
more suspects
all these terrorist gang members who are
being transferred to the terrorism
confinement Center currently four
thousand of them are never going to
return to the communities to the
brothers neighborhoods and cities of our
beloved El Salvador but at what cost
does it come due process has been
repeatedly violated so civil
organizations the majority of those in
prison have yet to even face trial those
arrested don't have the right to a
lawyer or even to be told why they were
detained
and many have been sent to prison after
Mass hearings often without evidence
presented
the government isn't using investigation
or intelligence to arrest people it's
not just that someone accuses someone
else and Anonymous phone call or their
policeman doesn't like the appearance of
a young person and they just capture
people and take them away the Salvadoran
authorities are unperturbed by the
criticism with Congress they've just
extended the emergency measures for
another month
foreign we need to continue fighting the
criminal structures we need to give
better service to the Salvadoran
families to guarantee their lives and
property
after years under the Yoke of the gangs
many of the population will support that
but not those waiting outside of
Salvadoran prisons hoping their loved
ones will be released
John Holman Al Jazeera